In the fall of 2017, we spotted an unexpected
visitor to our solar system from deep space.
We’d never seen anything like it!
It came out of nowhere, was on a surprising
trajectory, and it was MOVING FAST.
It wasn’t aliens, but it’s still just
fantastic.
This is Karen Meech.
I'm an astronomer at the Institute For Astronomy
University of Hawaii.
Her team spotted the UFO , and eventually:
Oumuamua.
It’s not aliens, it’s an asteroid.
But before you leave!
It’s an asteroid like none we’ve ever
observed before!
An asteroid from another star.
A piece of interstellar debris!
When I first heard about the detection I was
very excited because we expected that these
things should exist, but nobody had ever seen
one before.
Imagine that our solar system is a fish tank,
and we’re in the middle of it.
So we’re looking at our fish tank and trying
to learn about the whole world outside of
it too.
And then, suddenly and without warning something
gets thrown in to our tank and WHO KNOWS where
that thing is from?!
It’s completely different stuff!
From a whole different place!
ARE YOU EXCITED YET?
I KNOW RIGHT?!
That’s what happened here.
So here’s what we know…
We know that it is not from our solar system
based on the path it took through the solar
system.
We know it is the size of a football field,
and it’s rotating rapidly.
We also know, based on its orbit, where it
came from and where it is going.
We know it’s got no dust coming off it,
and it’s not icy, so it’s not a comet!
We know its color!
It’s RED!
Well, kinda.
Yes.
Well when you say red, people instantly picture
something red in color.
But what we mean astronomically is that it
more efficiently reflects the red light than
the blue light.
And so it may not necessarily look red, and
in fact we think this object is very dark.
And so it's just varying amounts of a very
dark surface reflecting the blue or the red
end of the spectrum.
Also, the shape was very unusual.
It was not what we were expecting.
For example, observations told us it’s 10
times longer than it is wide, but that’s
the Lower limit.
Yeah.
It’s 10 to 1…
At bare minimum.
The reason I say bare minimum is we were assuming
that the rotation axis was perpendicular to
our line of sight.
And we don't know that.
If the rotation axis were pointing at us as
in -- it’s spinning like a rectangular platter,
you can’t tell how big it really is!
If it's tilted over you can foreshortening,
in which case it could even be longer than
10 to 1.
And the only way to figure that out would
be to get its rotational light curve over
a long period of time and get it at all sorts
of different viewing angles, and we didn't
have that luxury.
They didn’t have that luxury, because they
didn’t know it was coming.
The asteroid was so shocking, Earth astronomers
didn’t even know it was there until it had
passed the sun already!
Which means astronomers around the world were
in a bit of a race against time.
You have to realize we had very little time
to observe it.
From time at which we realized what it was
until it was really too faint to do much science
to characterize it was less than about two
weeks.
if it hadn't come as close to the sun as it
did its path would have just been a straight
line through the solar system, but it got
close enough to the sun that the sun acts
like a gravitational slingshot
And that slingshot it really what saved us,
in terms of giving us time to do some science.
And normally you spend, you might spend a
month or so writing a careful proposal to
get telescope time that you would be awarded
six months later.
You get the data, you carefully analyze it.
So this was a real time crunch.
On top of that we know the surface of the
asteroid was bombarded by cosmic rays for
millions upon millions of years!
24.
In the end, the biggest discovery here isn’t
what we learned about Oumuamua, but that the
asteroid existed in the first place.
This is this tells us that they're out there
and there's probably a lot of them.
Before we wrap up here.
There are projects pointing telescopes at
Oumuamua to determine if it’s an interstellar
probe, or some kind of spacecraft.
I get that, it’s not been ruled out.
And I asked Karen what she thought and … well,
she had some feels.
Proving that it's not artificial, if there
was intelligence behind it would be really
difficult.
But this is entirely consistent with a natural
trajectory.
Now if it had deviated from this path suddenly,
that would be a good indication it's not natural,
but it didn't do that.
The surface materials are consistent with
natural things in the solar system, but so
is metal.
So that's not proving things one way or another.
It's consistent with being natural.
The size is consistent with being natural.
Just because we can't explain the elongated
shape doesn't mean it has to have an unnatural
explanation.
So given that it's entirely consistent, yeah
if you were gonna go out on the edge and say
it's something extraordinary you better have
extraordinary proof.
And given that it's totally consistent with
a natural object there's no proof of anything.
So now we know intergalactic objects do occasionally
fall into our little fish tank, and hopefully,
next time, we’ll know what to look for and
get even more data, and this armchair twitter
astronomer will be ready to heart every bit
of it.
Thanks for watching Seeker, make sure you
come back again for more videos, and if you
have suggestions for more topics, we’re
always looking, so let us know!
One last fun fact from Dr. Meech she got excited
about science by watching Star Trek with her
parents.
Same Karen.
Same.